Another Thing That Doctor Bright Is Not Allowed
To Do At The Foundation: Dr. Bright is not
allowed to interact with Dr. Clef without
the presence of a responsible administrator.
After an ordinary lunch meeting between the
two Doctors resulted in a dozen casualties,
several containment breaches, and a glob of
mashed potatoes stuck to the ceiling that
won’t budge no matter how hard the cleaning
staff scrubs, it was decided that the two
should not be in the same room without adequate
supervision.
There have been some follow-up questions (mainly
from Bright and Clef) about who counts as
adequate supervision, so let’s clarify:
Dr. Kondraki does not count.
Agent Strelnikov does not count.
Dr. Mann does not count.
So far, no one counts.
As soon as someone does count?
Trust us, you’ll know.
Don’t call us, we’ll call you.